[Music]
so is lighting the whole secret down
there yeah I think one of the best
things to do underwater is to sort of
meter for the for the background the
ambient and then maybe under expose that
just a little bit it kind of creates a
nice richly saturated backdrop and then
you use your strokes just as a little
bit of Phil Phil flashy you don't want
it to look overly lit you want it to
sort of just fill in the shadows and add
some color and detail but you know we'll
just kind of see how how the first few
frames look and then we can make
adjustments as as we go I think we might
have had a little equipment malfunction
I like the strobes they're not firing
well I mean that's what it's all about
right it's it's overcoming challenges
and figuring out what you need to do to
try to come back with something yeah
into things I started my work with some
terrestrial work with leatherback sea
turtles at night and you see the stars
in the sky and I did a long exposure
where the ocean glows with this green
luminescence yeah this was a very long
exposure and she was relatively still
for that time period but you know it's
like a primordial scene this is an
animal whose lineage dates back a
hundred million years they're older than
dinosaurs you know there was a time in
there incest tree where they crawled out
on the beaches and saw t-rex running by
and today in some places they crawl out
and see condominiums but here's this and
see kids running by zebra
does Wow you found a 15 millimeter lens
yeah breaking the rules that's okay oh
wait that puffer look at that that's
talked about personality
[Music]